[Applause]
i have returned
his armor may have a few dents in it
but the battle is far from over is
newcastle ever actually gonna qualify
he's fighting for us that's what matters
we'll get them next time
our new castle let's go newcastle
ew
bangalore is an imc jerk newcastle's a
real hero can i get a stuffy
please
hey it's a bit steep for a dog take good
care of him now next
newcastle is so cool
now you do know i repair that armor
sometimes right yes dad you remind me
all the time all right
okay time to go to bed baby girl stuffy
oh i'm no
knight in shining armor but i can find
your stuffy are you wearing your
protection bracelet mm-hmm you know i
never take this thing off
[Music]
where's our money renee fellas come on
no wonder you haven't gotten into the
games
look man it's not me
these crappy teammates are dragging me
down doesn't matter you haven't made it
in
and
you've got no other way to cover your
debts
not anymore
please believe me it's not my fault just
give me another shot
there's your shot
loser
[Music]
easy
easy big fella
we can work this out
leave harris valley and never come back
leave
but the forgotten families own this town
your hero sold it to us
and sadly
it is not nearly enough
no one here is safe
until my boss
gets paid there's got to be a better way
to sell this he couldn't settle it
deadbeat thought he could get into the
games to make the money
i'll
i'll do it
you must be joking
all right
i'm feeling generous
you got one shot
you fail the town burns
you win
you pay us back
with interest of course
fine
can't wait to catch your first match
you don't look all right
it's hilarious
trash man thinks he'll do better than me
you were supposed to protect these
people you think it's easy being a hero
don't talk
i'll get some help
hey
all right baby girl
hope this thing works
[Music]
see you soon sis